[MUSIC PLAYING]
ENOCH LAU: Hi.
I'm Enoch from the
Google Maps API team.
And we're here in the
factory in Berlin.
And we're here to listen to
developers try to [? collab, ?]
and here about some great
Maps API integrations.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATT TOON: You're
going to take a number
of different
components and create
a mapping application that
stores its data in the cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ED PARSONS: Geo
technology is everywhere,
and increasingly, it's
talking about everything.
MARTIN KLEPPE: Load this
kind of data on a map
and interact with this data.
ENOCH LAU: Here are just
a few tips and tricks
to maximize your usage of these.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: I really enjoyed it.
I learned a lot.
People were moving along
in a way that was--
people didn't get left behind.
SPEAKER 2: Usually, you need a
team to believe in a prototype.
Said, with a team like
that, you can do nice stuff.
[MUSIC PLAYING]